6 17 on your friday morning what's cool
at school last week we talked about what
we can do to make sure kids get to
school safely this week meet a couple of
clark county school district programs
that are doing just that
have a safe and wonderful school year
first up the ccsd's safe routes to
schools
celebrating new traffic signals in busy
residential areas spreading safety
messages and reminding us all of the
rules of the road do not make u-turns in
front of a school zone it is illegal
then it's the ccsd school bus drivers
staying hip with the kids in a tick-tock
video showing pre-travel tire inspection
making sure on-board access ramps are
good to go
and how's your engine compartment
[Applause]
i don't know that sounds like a personal
question
uh thanks to safe routes to school and
especially thanks to those ccsd bus
drivers
uh have you heard their hiring you
probably don't have to be in a tick tock
video we always want to know what's cool
at school so if you've got something let
us know cool it's cool under the
community tab at eightnewsnow.com or
just email cool at school at
eightnewsnow.com anybody here have a
tick tock
i don't we've we've talked about it
we've talked about doing the tick tock
thing i haven't jumped on everybody else
is on board but well for ccsd school bus
drivers are on tick tock come on
so uncle we're uncool but look who they
talk to every day they talk to the kids
every day